and to help make this a bigger and
bigger reality these people are have
they have a vision and they have a
concept of something they want to
accomplish that really wants to root the
community and they want to serve in the
best possible way to empower the Next
Generation instead of always being on
the back foot and kind of Defending
Islam and holding on barely holding on
to our religion and instead of that
putting ourselves in a position of power
putting ourselves in a position of
stability and that's what this religion
is about to be on the strong foot so
let's help them do that and put
ourselves on the strong foot together
inshallah so I hope you'll contribute to
this project I intend to also we're
doing a review yes we know Elon Musk is
a fascist who is now supporting Tommy
Robinson but the stocks of Tesla is
going down and what I'm going to be
doing today is a car review Top Gear
style of this particular car here as you
can see the model 3 and first thing I
will say is this car does look like a
Mazda and in fact it looks like a Mazda
3 and I did a bit of research to see why
this shape is qu quite similar to the
Mazda and there are some theories online
which I came across that the actual
designer one of the chief designers for
Mazda was also um employed for Tesla as
well so that's why it may be suggested
that some of the continuities here exist
between a Mazda and a Tesla now the
first thing I will say is that when you
try and open the door it's not intuitive
it's very unintuitive it's not like a
normal handle and for someone some who
doesn't know Tesla for example if you've
got a friend of yours and you know
they're trying to get into the car
they're trying to figure out this is
actually very inconveniency to be honest
with you so the first thing is look I'm
opening the thing getting in and let's
let's get in and see how it feels I am a
tall man I'm a very tall man but look at
this I mean what kind of space is this
I've taken this this back to the maximum
and my knee is hitting this massive you
know screen in the middle I feel like
come in the in an internet cafe actually
and what you'll notice here is flimsy
design sorry to say very flimsy very
cheap kind of design doesn't feel like
I'm in a in a car really you
know is this the glove compartment yes
this is the glove compartment but look
at this there's no handle for the glove
compartment we can't even we can't even
open this glove compartment the only way
to open the glove compartment is through
this this screen this gargantuan this um
you know obstruct ing screen that's in
the middle of this of this particular
place so so far not so good um let's
drive the car and see maybe if the
experience is going to be a little bit
different Abid
road yeah and now one thing I will say
I'm driving the car now is it's a very
jolty car if you put your foot down on
the accelerator a little bit it it just
jolts into action now it feels a bit
like you're driving a bumper car a fast
bumper car on the road like for let me
give you an example here put in a look
at that look at that look at the jolt
now some people would like that and say
well that's acceleration for if you
don't like it then don't get into fast
cars but it's not that it's it's just
the fact that it's the suspension is not
all that it's a bit rigid the handling
is not all that and it's just jolting
into action it's not smooth it's not
seamless you know as in with other cars
you can see it is fast it is a very fast
car but as I say it's kind of like jolty
and it's not a very comfortable EXP
experience and can you see these sounds
that keep coming out of the screen I
mean this is one of the Annoying
features of Tesla it just keeps making
sounds like this I mean people have
complained about for example the screen
and the auto drive um feature I mean the
auto drive feature itself in 2019 caused
a death it caused a fatality uh this has
been marketed as some kind of a
self-driving car and in fact it's not
that because many people will say that
the auto drive in in this vehicle is
absolutely abysmal I mean if it led to
just one fatality that's enough for us
to write it off to be honest and that
was in 2019 I think it led to other
accidents uh subsequently so they should
not be marketing a car like this as auto
drive when it leads to death of people
in in in in Florida or any other play
place in the world really so I'm driving
the car as I say my knee is banging onto
the screen it's just making a lot of
noise you know it doesn't feel like I'm
in a car it feels very cheap I mean it's
banging all over the place you can see
it's very uncomfortable you know what I
mean it's how's the suspension the
suspension is really really rigid I mean
I mean what kind of suspension is this
anyway I mean to be honest with the same
kind of money we're talking about what
£50,000 if you get this car brand new
this car if for the same kind of money
you can get a Q5 you can get an Audi Q5
five you can get so many car if if
you're going in the secondhand car
market you can get so many you can
probably get probably super car there
fantastic cars you can get for that
money um if you wanted something fast if
you wanted something flashy but if
you're talking about like for like
comparisons then compare this to the BMW
I4 the BMW I4 you're in a car right the
BMW I4 you're in a car which is a BMW
and it feels like a BMW it feels like
you are driving you don't have to press
the screen to open the glove compartment
you don't have these tacky kind of
interior designs you don't have this
cheap feeling you don't feel like you're
you're driving a USB you still get the
German Ingenuity you still get you know
the BMW logo as well you you get
something for your money you don't get
like what seems to be a Mazda okay an
electronic Mazda which um is pretty
rough from the inside and this let's be
honest let's be completely completely
honest about this if you're driving a
car like this and the the owner of Tesla
is a fascist or you know somebody who's
openly you know endorsing Tommy Robinson
in the far right there's also kind of
like you don't want to be associated
with that you're you're a you're a
normal member of society you don't want
to be associated with Tommy Robinson by
driving this car now it's almost a
political you're making a political
point that you know I am funding
somebody who is associated with one of
the most extreme right-wing person
actually in prison a
criminal in the UK today so yeah I mean
there are some obviously positives of
the car I mean I'm sure you're going to
save money on elect electricity if if
you're coming from gas but the thing is
once again it's very
inconveniencing very inconveniencing if
you're trying to find those Electric
electrical plugs and things like that if
you're trying to go from place to place
that's the problem with all electric
cars I must admit if you're going from
from London to Birmingham you're going
to have to stop the car and charge it
and it's going to be an hour for example
or maybe half an hour or something like
that to charge it fully so this is this
is the fast charging that's fast
charging that's it's like going
backwards let's be honest in technology
because had electric cars been the
default position right and then and then
petrol came out and you can just
completely refill your tank in in about
a minute people would be calling that
and Advan in technology but somehow
we've moved away from 2-minute charge 2
minute refueling to 30 minutes charging
and that is somehow a progression in
technological uh in technology or in in
convenience for for a driver I don't
think so I think really what we're doing
is for the money we're not getting our
money is worth and in fact it's a fad
this is an overrated car I've had a very
underwhelming experience and very like
uncomfortable experience in this vehicle
I have to say um I would not be
recommending this car for the money I
mean we're talking about 50,000 pound
50,000 what can you get for 50,000 look
at that look at that couldn't even deal
with the B
unbelievable well I think that's all I
have to say about this vehicle here and
um I think it'd be a fool to actually to
pay that much money for a car like this
one thing I will say that's good about
this car is the cameras are quite nice
there's cameras all around the I think
probably that's the biggest selling
point the screen okay you've got you
know the screen but you're not going to
be paying £50,000 for a screen let's be
honest who in their right mind pays
£50,000 for a massive screen and a and
and electronic you know vehicle that
kind of comes with it really cuz the the
the main event of the evening here is
the screen by the way I mean this is the
main thing about this car you're you're
buying a big screen with something that
surrounds it
okay and cameras around it and to be
honest with you as I say this whole
self-driving thing I think is it's
actually a negative thing because the
whole point driving is an experience
driving is an experience driving is
something you do you want to be in
control of you don't want to be in a car
and the car is making the decisions for
you and these kind of things and telling
you annoying you and it can lock you out
the system apparently if you keep
pressing it a couple of times four five
times says stop it it tells you to pull
over sometimes tells you to pull over
how dare this car have that kind of say
on me who is this car this to tell me to
like a parent infantilizing me telling
me to to stop and pull over like a
parent
yeah instead of instead of claiming that
you can do auto drivve and these kind of
things just do the basics properly for
God's sake this is not no one's going to
be wanting to be sitting in a car that's
driving itself whil you're maybe
watching a YouTube video that's not the
driving exp you're killing the Driving
Experience our lives are not centered
around screens we've got enough screens
bro uh when I'm driving I actually want
to get away from screens why are you
giving me a big screen okay when I'm
driving why you giving me a big screen
in front of my face I'm actually trying
to get away from the screen I'm trying
to get Morning Light I'm trying to get
the natural elements on me why are you
giving me a massive I don't know how
many inch screen this is in a car this
is UN it's inappropriate really it's an
inappropriate feature and if you really
wanted a big screen in a car you can get
the byd it's a it's a Chinese electric
uh alternative much cheaper and many
would say much better quite frankly than
this Tesla and in many ways much more
original maybe not with a screen maybe
they did take that from Tesla but you
could argue at least in the design look
the design of this car is akin to really
a Timex comparison to a Rolex I mean in
this case the Rolex would be a Mazda
unfortunately for for for the people
here at Tesla but what I'm saying to you
is why would you if it's the design
because I'm trying to figure out what
the appeal is here if it's the design
that you're looking for then just get a
Mazda then get a Mazda 3 and you'll get
all the the nice Aesthetics but you'll
get a proper Driving Experience you can
open the glove compartment properly you
can drive the car properly you can still
accelerate quite fast you can still do
kind of that's what you want but let's
be honest why do you need such a fast
acceleration in if you're going to be in
a big city when there's cameras
everywhere tell me what you're going to
do with that oh fast a couple of seconds
and come back down it's not going to
really benefit you're not in you're not
there's no autobomb in the UK you can't
go 150 70 miles an hour whatever it is
so let's just let's just make things
convenient for ourselves because this is
not a convenient car look it's really
really uncomfortable and many of my
friends and you'll see this have
actually have have kind of like left
this car um because they they've had it
and they've kind of sold it or they
tried to sell it and some they can't
find anyone to sell it and if you go
online today to like one of these car
dealers you'll find so many of these
cars on there being sold the question is
if this car is as good as it says it is
why are so many people trying to sell
them why are so many people trying to
get rid of them why are so many people
complaining about
them we' spoke about Tesla for a long
time that's a very negative experience
experience but what is a positive
experience is reciting the Quran okay
and I tell you what
technology has taken us to another place
and that I have to say this and I do
mean this one of the best apps for
reciting the Quran is the Quran
app it is because it does employ look it
does employ all these gamified features
it has all these habit trackers and all
these things has all these things in a
very convenient format because let's be
honest we are living in a of screens we'
spoken about that but if you're on your
screen you might as well do something
productive if you know that you're going
to be on your screen at least some of
your screen time can be dedicated to
something really productive something
spiritual something which you can
compete with others the Quran
says and let the competitors compete on
this okay and what is this it is good
deeds and stuff and and Quran app does a
beautiful job I'll I'll put a link below
to the Quran app because that is
something of all this negative things
that we spoke about in this video that
is positive about this video